but we're all adults it's that's a lot
of that is is like left over
and i can drop it it's just sort of me
getting used to
not thinking that way um but it's really
hard for me because i
feel an expectation or maybe i've made
it up in my head that i
i come off a certain way i i
i need to be a certain way to maybe be
uh accepted or
whatever that's just the way i'm
expected to show up that it almost
sometimes is like
unless i can show up that way i'm not
going
instead of just showing up where i am
um so that's my that i have to
that i have to drop because nobody's
asking that of me
right and the people of my life you know
now but i think it's part of the reason
like i have a ton of
social media anxiety i have a lot
just like even i talked about sharing
sharing my life or talking
it's and i think a lot of it kind of
comes from that um
yeah i asked james roday i text dulay
and roday
but that rhymed do lay in row day delay
and road day
so i just said hey anything i should say
to maggie i'm interviewing her she goes
no
just have fun she probably won't get too
deep or personal not really her jam but
she's awesome
yeah so that's what you just said so he
knows you and then
dule says just seeing this tell her i
love her
i miss her and i can't wait for us to
all suck it again
wow so there was that yeah
i think he was talking about the acting
thing let's just suck it again let's
rock this
we say that it's a thing on cyprus oh it
is
suck it yeah yeah oh i should know that
i'll suck it again
but uh yeah knows me really well
sorry was that me looking like i i'm
talk for something no do it again
say the second line i'm not doing it
again suck it
no that was just a a
that was an off the cuff one time thing
that i cannot i love that it's so cute
though i got it
oh yeah i know
you